Hi there, everybody. Ira Glass here. Today's program is a rerun, but from a long time ago, the year 2000. So forgive any anachronisms you hear. That's a word a person doesn't get to say very often outside of the SATs.
大家好，我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是重播，但来自很久以前的2000年。所以，如果你们听到任何过时的内容，请多包涵。毕竟在SAT考试之外，人们很少有机会用到“时代错误”这个词。
Forgive any anachronisms. It's back when the person at the center of the story still smoked, back before Notre Dame started burning. Anyway, it's a great show. We haven't aired it in forever. A total favorite. In honor of Bastille Day this month, here we go.
请原谅任何过时的表述。那时故事的主人公还会抽烟，那时圣母院还没有开始燃烧。总之，这是一期很棒的节目，我们已经很久没播了，一直很受大家喜爱。为了纪念本月的巴士底日，让我们开始吧。
It's a grey, rainy day in Paris.
巴黎是一个阴雨绵绵的灰色日子。
[CHATTER]
[嘈杂声]
A silky line of tourists waits on the grounds of an old medieval palace, now one of the most famous museums in the world. I'm with David Sedaris who lives nearby.
一队游客排着长龙，伫立在这座中世纪老宫殿的庭院里，如今这里是世界上最著名的博物馆之一。和我在一起的是住在附近的戴维·塞达里斯。
So, David, explain where we are.
那么，戴维，解释一下我们在哪里。
We're at the Louvre. And this is the closest I've ever come. I've never set foot inside the Louvre.
我们在卢浮宫。这是我离它最近的一次。我从来没踏进过卢浮宫。
So you've lived in Paris for how long?
那你住在巴黎多久了？
Two years. But I still haven't visited. I didn't see the point. Why come to Paris and go to the one place where you're not allowed to smoke? As a matter of fact, it's my goal to be the only person who's come to Paris and has never set foot in the Louvre.
两年了。但我还是没去参观过。我觉得没意义。为什么来到巴黎却要去一个不允许抽烟的地方？事实上，我的目标是成为唯一一个来到巴黎却从未踏进过卢浮宫的人。
You live how far from here?
你住离这儿多远？
I'm probably about a 12-minute walk, 15-minute walk from the Louvre. I'm close to Notre Dame, too, but I've never gone in there either. It just doesn't interest me.
走路大概12到15分钟吧。我离圣母院也很近，但我从来没进去过。那对我没什么吸引力。
I mean, I think so many people come here and they feel like they have to do certain things because somebody told them to do it, or they're going to go home and people will say, what do you mean you didn't see the Pantheon? What do you mean you didn't go into the Louvre?
我是说，我觉得很多人来到这里，感觉他们必须做某些事情，因为有人告诉他们该做，或者他们回家后别人会问：“你什么意思？你没看万神殿？你没去卢浮宫？”
So I'm guessing that a good number of these people are just standing here because somebody told them that they should do it. I don't think that they're all museum-goers at home. I don't know. Do people look back and remember the experience of standing in front of a painting?
所以我猜，这些在这里排队的人中，有很大一部分只是因为别人告诉他们应该来。我不觉得他们在国内都是爱逛博物馆的人。不知道。人们回首往事时，会记得站在画前的那种体验吗？
I might remember eating something, or buying something, or seeing something, like an accident, or somebody who's really twisted up in some way, but not looking at a painting. Maybe I'm wrong. Maybe, for them, it doesn't get any better than this. But I don't know. Just from people that I know that have come here, they go to the Louvre because somebody told them that they have to.
我可能会记得吃过什么、买过什么，或者看到什么，比如一场事故，或者某个看起来扭曲的人，而不是盯着一幅画看。也许我错了。也许对他们来说，这已经是最棒的体验了。但我不知道。从我认识的人来看，他们去卢浮宫只是因为有人告诉他们必须去。
Today on our radio program, where you might go in Paris instead of the Louvre. I spent three days with David Sedaris, who writes a lot about what it's like to live in France. He never saw the Eiffel Tower, or the Rodin Museum, or the famous cemetery where Marcel Proust and Jim Morrison are buried. No historical sites. Nothing having to do with the culture or language of the people of France. But if you want to know the best place to buy a model of a rotten tooth, or a collection of leeches, or a life-sized replica of a human head with the top cut off so you can see what's inside, David did show me that.
今天在我们的广播节目中，我们将带你去看看在巴黎可以去哪里，而不是去卢浮宫。我和戴维·塞达里斯相处了三天，他写了很多关于在法国生活是什么样的文章。他从没看过埃菲尔铁塔、罗丹博物馆，或者埋葬着马塞尔·普鲁斯特和吉姆·莫里森的那座著名公墓。没有历史古迹。没有任何与法国人的文化或语言有关的东西。但如果你想知道买一个烂牙模型、一盒水蛭，或者是头顶被切开以便观察内部的人类头部模型最好的地方在哪里，戴维确实带我去过。
This is a pretty good medical supply store. These body parts that they have here, they're handmade and hand-painted. And they're not nearly as expensive as you would think that they would be.
这是一家很不错的医疗用品店。他们这里的身体部位模型都是手工制作和手工涂漆的。而且它们并不像你想象的那么贵。
I think I got my sister Gretchen a stomach-- or a backbone. I got her a backbone made out of papier-mache for Christmas. And I think it probably cost about $60, which is a great price for a backbone.
我想我给姐姐格雷琴买过一个胃，或者是脊椎。圣诞节我送了她一个纸糊的脊椎。我想那大概花了60美元，对于一个脊椎来说是个很棒的价格。
Today in our program, Americans in Paris and how our Paris sometimes has very little to do with the one familiar to the locals. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
今天在我们的节目中，我们将讨论在巴黎的美国人，以及为什么我们眼中的巴黎有时与当地人熟悉的巴黎几乎毫无关系。来自芝加哥WBEZ，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
The French government says that three and a half million Americans visited Paris last year. The US government says it was more like two and a half million. Either way, it is a lot more than the actual population of Paris, which is 2.1 million.
法国政府称去年有350万美国游客造访巴黎。美国政府则称大概是250万。不管怎样，这都远多于巴黎210万的实际人口。
Americans have dreamy and romantic ideas about Paris, more than other places, I think. In 1944, at the liberation of Paris from the Nazis, EB White wrote, "Probably one of the dullest stretches of prose in any man's library is the article in Paris in the Encyclopedia Britannica. Yet when we heard the news of liberation, being unable to think of anything else to do, we sat down and read it straight through, from beginning to end.
我认为，相比其他地方，美国人对巴黎有着更多梦幻且浪漫的想象。1944年，在巴黎从纳粹手中解放时，E·B·怀特写道：“《大英百科全书》中关于巴黎的文章可能是任何人书架上最枯燥的文字之一。然而，当我们听到解放的消息时，因为想不出其他该做的事，我们坐下来把它从头到尾读了一遍。”
Paris, we began, capital of France and of the Department of San, situated on the Ile de la Cite, the Ile St. Louis, and the Ile Louvier in the Seine, as well as on both banks of the Seine. The words seemed like the beginning of a great poem. A feeling of simple awe overtook us as we slowly turned the page and settled down to a study of the city's weather graph and the view of the Seine looking east from Notre Dame. The rainfall is rather evenly distributed, continued the encyclopedist. Evenly distributed, we thought to ourselves, like the tears of those who love Paris."
“巴黎，我们开始读，法国及塞纳省的省会，坐落于塞纳河上的西岱岛、圣路易岛和卢维耶岛，以及塞纳河的两岸。这些词听起来像是伟大诗歌的开篇。一种单纯的敬畏感笼罩了我们，我们缓缓翻过页面，沉浸于研究这座城市的气候图和从圣母院向东望去的塞纳河景。‘降雨量相当均匀地分布着，’百科全书编纂者继续写道。‘均匀分布着，’我们心里想，‘就像那些热爱巴黎的人的泪水一样。’”
But what is it actually like in Paris, really, without the rose-colored glasses, if you're American? Well, our This American Life team headed overseas to find out. And let's just pause for a moment. What exactly does that sound like, you wonder? Well, here's a recording.
但如果不戴有色眼镜，作为一个美国人，在巴黎真实的体验到底是怎样的呢？好吧，我们的《美国生活》团队前往海外去一探究竟。让我们先停顿片刻。你可能好奇那听起来是什么样？好吧，录音在这里。
Well, in act one of our program today, "Him Talk Pretty Three Days," David Sedaris gives me and you a walking tour of his favorite places in the city that he calls home. Act two, "Ca Vie Americaine," in which we try to answer the question, what is it that some Americans see in Paris anyway? What is the draw?
在今天节目的第一幕，“他说了三天漂亮话”，戴维·塞达里斯带我和你们领略了他心目中那座城市的徒步旅行。第二幕，“那法式美国生活”，我们试图回答这个问题：美国人到底在巴黎看到了什么？吸引力究竟何在？
Act three, "Notes of a Native Daughter--" why it helps sometimes to pretend your French accent is worse than it really is, and why it's harder to cut into a movie line in Paris than in New York, and whether it is the same for African-Americans these days in Paris as it was in the heyday of James Baldwin and Sidney Bechet. Answers. Stay with us.
第三幕，“一位本土女儿的笔记”——为什么有时候假装你的法语口音比实际更差会有帮助，为什么在巴黎排队加塞比在纽约更难，以及今天的非裔美国人在巴黎是否和詹姆斯·鲍德温与西德尼·贝谢鼎盛时期一样。答案即将揭晓。请收听。
Act one, "Him Talk Pretty Three Days." Two years ago, at the age of 41, barely speaking French, David Sedaris moved to Paris. He had no special feelings about France, no particular interest in the French. It would be the same if it's Korea, he said to me, a sentence that, I think, if the French ever heard that he said it, they would deport him.
第一幕，“他说了三天漂亮话”。两年前，41岁的戴维·塞达里斯在几乎不会说法语的情况下搬到了巴黎。他对法国没有什么特别的感情，对法国人也没有什么特别的兴趣。他对我说了这样一句话：“如果搬到韩国，也是一样的。”我想，如果法国人听到他这么说，肯定会把他驱逐出境。
He moved for two reasons-- one, his boyfriend Hugh had a rundown house in Normandy, and, two, why not? And over the course of two years, he has written extensively about his experience in stories for the radio, for magazines, and for his newest book. In his stories, David portrays life in Paris as a series of humiliations and near-humiliations. And if you hang out with him for a few days, you realize he is not exaggerating much.
他搬到这里有两个原因：第一，他的男友休在诺曼底有一座破旧的房子；第二，为什么不呢？在两年多的时间里，他为广播、杂志和他的新书撰写了大量关于他经历的文章。在故事中，戴维将巴黎的生活描绘成一系列的羞辱和差点被羞辱的经历。如果你和他待上几天，你会意识到他并没有太夸张。
This is my worst nightmare right here.
这就是我最大的噩梦。
We'd barely gone three blocks from his apartment on our walking tour Paris when he stopped on the sidewalk.
我们的徒步游巴黎才刚刚走出三个街区，他就停在了人行道上。
OK, my lighter has run out of fluid, which would mean that I would have to ask somebody for a match. And so what I would say is, hello, do you have some fire? And I so hate saying that that I usually carry four lighters on me so I always have a backup.
好吧，我的打火机没油了，这意味着我必须向别人借火。所以我要说的是：“你好，你有火吗？”我非常讨厌说这句话，所以我通常随身带着四个打火机，以防万一。
So you're just digging into your bag here.
所以你是在包里翻找东西。
Extra cigarettes. I know I must have a lighter in here. I will not spend the afternoon asking people if they have fire.
多余的香烟。我知道我包里肯定有一个打火机。我绝不会把下午的时间浪费在问别人有没有火这件事上。
I was curious about David's thoughts about Paris, precisely because he was never somebody who had any special feelings for the place. He didn't move here with his head full of Ernest Hemingway, Gertrude Stein, Sartre, and Proust. He was a blank slate.
我对戴维关于巴黎的想法很好奇，正是因为他从来都不是一个对这个地方有什么特殊情感的人。他搬到这里时，脑子里并没有塞满海明威、格特鲁德·斯坦、萨特和普鲁斯特。他是一张白纸。
And so for several hours every day I was in Paris, David would walk me to the places he finds most interesting. And the first thing I learned was this. It is so traumatic to learn a new language that a lot of David's experience of the city, a lot of his personal geography of Paris, has to do simply with where people are cruel to him when he speaks and where they aren't.
因此，我在巴黎的每一天，戴维都会带我逛他觉得最有趣的地方。我学到的第一件事就是：学习一门新语言是如此痛苦，以至于戴维对这座城市的很多体验，他个人对于巴黎的地理认知，其实仅仅与人们在他说话时对他是否残酷有关。
This is a hardware store where the owner and the people who work there are really, really nice to me. I buy things here all the time. And I buy things that I don't even need just because they're so kind. And they generally just start laughing right when I walk in the door.
这是一家五金店，店主和员工对我真的、真的很好。我一直在这里买东西。我甚至会买一些我根本不需要的东西，只是因为他们太友善了。他们通常在我进门时就会开始笑。
And then the owner will call his assistants out of the back room and say, he's back, he's back! And I buy things like-- I bought a heating element so I could make tea in my hotel room, because I had to go to Germany. So I could go in and say, hello, I am looking for a stick that make the water hot, hot today.
然后店主会把助手从后室叫出来说：“他回来了，他回来了！”我买了一些东西，比如——我买了一个加热棒，这样我就能在酒店房间里泡茶，因为我要去德国。所以我进去说：“你好，我在找一种能让水变热的棍子，今天就要热的。”
So I say really stupid things when I go in there. But I only say it in French. But they're incredibly good sports.
我进去时确实会说些很蠢的话。但我只用法语说。但他们非常宽容。
And I bought an ironing board. And I was able to say, hello, it has been three weeks. I bought an iron. Now, today, I look for a table that might work with my iron. Have you such a table?
我还买了一块熨衣板。我能说：“你好，已经三周了。我买了一个熨斗。现在，今天，我正在找一张能配合我熨斗的桌子。你有这样的桌子吗？”
And he said, ah, an ironing board, and went and got one out of the back. But he's really, really nice. And it's a place I can always count on where somebody is going to be good to me.
他说：“啊，熨衣板，”然后去后面拿了一个出来。他真的、真的很好。这是我总是可以依靠的地方，在这里总有人会对我好。
Do we want to walk in the hardware store? Do we need anything? Do they sell batteries?
我们要进五金店吗？我们需要什么吗？他们卖电池吗？
Yeah.
对。
Could you get me some AA batteries for the camera?
你能帮我买些相机的五号电池吗？
Sure.
当然。
We need four. I'll pay.
我们需要四个。我来付钱。
It's a tiny store, just enough room for a few customers to stand, a store that's taller than it is wide, with shelves full of merchandise running up to the ceiling, plus brooms, feather dusters, baskets simply hanging over our heads to be retrieved by a hook on the end of a stick.
这是一家很小的店，只够几个顾客站立，店面长宽比很特别，货架上的商品一直堆到天花板，还有扫帚、鸡毛掸子、篮子，直接悬挂在我们的头顶上，用棍子末端的钩子取下来。
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
[法语对话]
This is my boyfriend, David says, trying to say, this is my friend. He is making a documentary of my life. He tapes everything.
这是我的男朋友，戴维试图解释说，这是我的朋友。他正在为我的生活制作纪录片。他录下一切。
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
[法语对话]
We pay, there's small talk, and we're back on the street in less than a minute and a half.
我们付了钱，闲聊了几句，不到一分半钟我们就回到了街上。
See, that's what's so nice about that guy. I went in and he said, I haven't seen you for a long time. Have you been on vacation? And that's just worth the world to me. That is so incredibly nice, for somebody to notice your absence.
看，这就是那个人如此可贵的地方。我进去的时候他说：“好久没见到你了。你去度假了吗？”对于我来说，有人能注意到你的缺席，简直是意义非凡。
Some shopkeepers don't notice him. He'd been buying his newspaper from the same woman in his neighborhood seven days a week for over a year. And recently she said to him out of the blue, are you a tourist here on vacation?
有些店主并不关注他。他在这片街区从同一个女人那里买报纸，一周七天，持续了一年多。最近，她突然对他说：“你是来度假的游客吗？”
And I said, I've been coming here and buying my newspaper every day for the last 19 months. No, I'm not on vacation. I have an apartment around the corner.
我说：“过去19个月里，我每天都来这儿买报纸。不，我没有度假。我就住在拐角处的公寓里。”
But it took that long for her even to acknowledge that she had seen me before. But that's why I go there everyday. I was waiting for that moment, for her to recognize me.
但她花了那么久才承认她以前见过我。但这就是我每天去那儿的原因。我在等那一刻，等她认出我来。
We go into a chocolate shop and a bookstore and a cafe. And each place we go, if there's a little conversation, just normal small talk, and it goes OK, he's really delighted and can recite it all for me afterwards, line by line. When he first moved here, when his French class wasn't going so well, he was constantly being scolded by people for not understanding the simplest things-- directions, prices, the proper change. People here are crazy about exact change, he swears to me. He realized at some point that he could make it all feel better if he transformed himself from the inept foreigner to the inept foreigner with a charge card.
我们走进一家巧克力店、一家书店和一家咖啡馆。我们要去的每一个地方，如果有简短的交谈，只是普通的寒暄，如果进行得顺利，他会非常高兴，随后能逐字逐句地复述给我听。刚搬到这里时，当他的法语课进展不顺利时，他经常因为听不懂最简单的事情而被人们训斥——指示、价格、正确的零钱。他发誓说这里的人对找零钱非常疯狂。他在某个时刻意识到，如果他把自己从一个无能的外国人变成一个带有信用卡、依然无能的外国人，事情会好办一些。
People will be really nice to you if you spend a lot of money. So then I just started going out and buying things. I could have a bad day in school. I'd go out after school and buy a desk, or pricey lamps.
如果你花很多钱，人们会真的对你很好。所以我就开始出去买东西。在学校过得不好，下课后我就会去买张桌子，或者是贵价的灯。
Because people were unfailingly nice while I was writing out that check. And I would say the most screwed up thing, and they would say, oh, you speak so well. And they would compliment me.
因为当我写支票时，人们总是无一例外地友善。我会说些最糟糕的话，他们会说：“哦，你法语说得真好。”他们会赞美我。
And I would feel so good. And then I would leave, and I would think, wait a minute. And it took a while to get that under control.
我会感觉很好。然后我会离开，我会想：等一下。那花了我好一阵子才控制住。
So just observing your day, as an outsider, I feel like you've put yourself into this position where the smallest human acts of kindness have turned out to mean so much.
所以作为局外人观察你的一天，我觉得你把自己置于这样一个境地：最微小的人性善意竟然变得意义重大。
They have, whereas before, they were things that I didn't really think about. It doesn't take much to make me happy now. Whereas before, I feel like it took quite a bit.
确实如此，而在此之前，这些是我从未考虑过的事情。现在，不需要太多东西就能让我快乐。而以前，我觉得需要相当多东西才能让我满足。
Is your experience here more of a feeling of adventure or more a feeling of humiliation?
你在那里的经历更多是一种冒险的感觉，还是羞辱的感觉？
It's more a feeling of humiliation. It would be a feeling of adventure if I were a different type of person, if I were a more adventurous person. But for me to get on a train and go to Switzerland, I don't think, oh, good, I get to have an adventure. I think, oh, great, I get to make an ass out of myself in two different languages.
更多是羞辱的感觉。如果我是另一种人，如果我是一个更爱冒险的人，那会是一种冒险的感觉。但对我来说，坐火车去瑞士，我不会想：“哦，太好了，我要去冒险了。”我会想：“哦，太棒了，我又要用两种不同的语言丢人现眼了。”
Because that's what I wind up doing. In Germany, they always include breakfast with your hotel. I'm not a breakfast eater. But I want a cup of coffee or something.
因为我最终总是那样。在德国，酒店总是包含早餐。我不是一个吃早餐的人。但我想要一杯咖啡之类的。
And I stayed at a hotel in Germany-- I don't remember the town-- the last time I was there. And so I go downstairs to have my breakfast, and there's six people seated at a table. And usually they've got lots of tables. But here, there's only one table.
上次去的时候，我住在一间德国酒店——我不记得是哪个镇了。我下楼去吃早餐，桌边坐着六个人。通常他们有很多桌子。但这里只有一张桌子。
And I'm thinking, well, I don't really want to sit with six people. But if I turn around and leave, then they'll think that I'm being rude. So I've gotten this far. So I have to sit down at the table with these six people.
我在想，嗯，我真的不想和六个人坐在一起。但如果我转身离开，他们会觉得我没礼貌。我已经走到这一步了。所以我不得不和这六个人坐在那张桌子上。
So I pull out a chair. And the man says something to me in German. And I say, oh, no, just coffee for me. I'm fine with that.
我拉开一把椅子。那个男人用德语对我说了什么。我说：“哦，不，只要咖啡就行。我没关系。”
And what he was trying to tell me was that I was in his kitchen. This was the kitchen of the owner. And this was the owner of the hotel and his family sitting down to breakfast.
而他试图告诉我的是，我进了他的厨房。这是老板的厨房。这是酒店老板和他家人坐下来吃早餐的地方。
I just saw this door and I opened it, and I was in their quarters. And then he had to go and wake up his nine-year-old so his nine-year-old could come and explain to me in English that, in fact, the dining room was downstairs. And so I didn't see it as an adventure. It just happened.
我只是看到了这扇门，我就打开了，然后我闯进了他们的私人空间。然后他不得不去叫醒他九岁的孩子，好让那个九岁的孩子来用英语向我解释：餐厅其实在楼下。所以我没觉得那是什么冒险。事情就这么发生了。
David moved here at a particular moment in his life. After years of making his living cleaning apartments and carrying furniture, he finally had published books, made the bestseller list, was on the radio, went on tours, and filled 2,000 and 5,000-seat halls with people who wanted to hear him read. And I think most people are built to take only so much of that, to have people think that we're somebody.
戴维在他人生中的特定时刻搬到了这里。在做了多年清洁工和搬运家具的工作后，他终于出版了书，进入了畅销书排行榜，上了广播，参加了巡回演出，坐满了2000到5000人的大厅，这些人想听他朗读。我认为大多数人只能承受那么多，只能承受人们认为我们“是个角色”。
I think, for most people, for people who are not hopeless egomaniacs, there is a normal balancing that has to happen, of believing that they're a somebody to believing that they're a nobody. There's a ratio, a balance that has to happen in most people's heads. I've known David for 10 years.
我想，对于大多数人，对于不是无可救药的自我膨胀者的人来说，正常地在“相信自己是个大人物”和“相信自己是个小人物”之间需要有一种平衡。大多数人的脑子里都需要有一种平衡。我认识戴维10年了。
And I think that what happened to him is that the somebody side of that equation got crazily inflated, fantastically inflated. And so the nobody side had to hyper-inflate to catch up. They had to balance out. If a nation of book-buying adults was going to tell him how great he was back home, he needed an entire second nation of adults reminding him that, really, how important was he?
我认为发生在他身上的事情是，等式中“大人物”的那一边被疯狂地膨胀了，极其地膨胀了。所以“小人物”的那一边必须过度膨胀来跟上脚步。它们必须平衡起来。如果国内的一群买书的成年人要告诉他他是多么了不起，他就需要另一群成年人提醒他：他到底有多重要？
Yeah, that's exactly the case. When I do go back, it's not like going from-- I don't know-- having an audience to being anonymous. It's "Beneath the Planet of the Apes." It's going from having an audience to being a foreigner, which is the lowest lifeform, to be a foreigner.
是的，情况确实如此。当我回去的时候，那种感觉不是从拥有观众变成默默无闻。那是《猿人星球》。那是从拥有观众变成一个外国人，这是最低等的生命形式，成为一个外国人。
When you were a kid, were you feeling humiliated a lot?
你小时候经常感到羞辱吗？
Yeah. I mean, I always had. I didn't want to open my mouth, because I lisped and I sounded like a girl. So it's a feeling that I'm used to. Really, the feeling that I get here is more comfortable to me.
是的。我是说，我一直都有。我不想开口，因为我口齿不清，听起来像个女孩子。所以我习惯了这种感觉。真的，我在这里得到的这种感觉，对我来说更舒服。
[CHATTER]
[嘈杂声]
One day, David takes me to a cafe that he goes to all the time, often alone. And I'm surprised when he tells me that he is somebody who, until recently, had trouble going to a restaurant or cafe by himself just to get a cup of coffee.
有一天，戴维带我去他经常去的咖啡馆，通常是一个人去。他告诉我他直到最近才敢独自去餐厅或咖啡馆买杯咖啡，我感到很惊讶。
Because I'm always afraid that they're not going to see me there. And then I'll just be stuck there. And other people will say, look, no one's waited on that guy, and he's been there for half an hour, and he doesn't know what to do with himself. I get terribly self-conscious in those situations. I mean, do you?
因为我总是害怕他们看不到我。然后我就被困在那里了。其他人会说：“看，没人理那个家伙，他都坐了半个小时了，他不知道该怎么办。”在那种情况下，我会变得特别局促不安。我是说，你呢？
I'm not scared that, if I'm sitting in a restaurant alone, they won't see me. I assume that they'll see me and that they'll wait on me. Do you know what I mean?
我不怕如果我独自坐在餐厅里，他们会看不见我。我默认他们会看到我，并为我服务。你明白我的意思吗？
It's a business. And they need the money. And so they'll usually wait on you.
这是一家生意。他们需要钱。所以他们通常会服务你。
No, but I'm always convinced that they don't see me and that they're not going to wait on me. And it just seemed to happen to me so many times in my life, that I would go into a place, and then you have to pretend like you're leaving of your own volition, like you've been waiting for somebody. And then you look at your watch, like, darn, well, I guess they're not going to show. I'm not going to sit around here and wait any longer.
不，我总是确信他们看不见我，他们不会服务我。这种情况在我一生中发生过太多次了，我走进一家店，然后你必须假装你是自愿离开的，好像你在等人。然后你看看手表，心想：“该死，好吧，看来他们不会来了。我不会在这里坐着干等了。”
And you make this whole little play that you do. But really, nobody's watching it. But it's very elaborate. And then you can get up and leave.
然后你上演了一整场小戏。但实际上，没人看。但它非常复杂。然后你就可以起身离开。
The thing is, what you're describing is, you're sitting there, and you think that other people are watching in such a way that they will think, oh, that guy hasn't gotten waited on?
问题是，你所描述的是：你坐在那里，你觉得别人都在盯着看，以至于他们会想：“哦，那个家伙没被服务？”
Because that's what I do. I look at people like that. And I notice when it happens to other people. And it's because I look at things like that that I imagine that everybody else is.
因为我就是这样做的。我看待别人就是这样。我注意到了这种情况发生在别人身上。正是因为我盯着这些事情看，所以我才想象每个人也都在看。
This turns out to be quite a burden to carry into a foreign country. If somebody does something stupid in front of him, David says, he goes home, writes it down, tells his friends, sometimes turns it into a story that he reads in front of thousands or tens of thousands of strangers. And so when he says something stupid in French, which he does daily, he believes that it is possible the shopkeepers or waiters just shrug it off and never think about it again. But it seems just as possible that they go, tell their friends, and laugh at him.
这被证明是一个背负到国外的沉重负担。如果有人在他面前做了蠢事，戴维说，他会回家，写下来，告诉他的朋友，有时会把它变成他在成千上万陌生人面前朗读的故事。所以当他在法语中说了蠢话时，他每天都在做，他相信店主或服务员可能只是耸耸肩，再也不会想这件事。但看起来他们很有可能回家后告诉朋友，然后嘲笑他。
That's why I get so embarrassed of the way that I speak. It's because I go home and I write everything down. That's the way I am. I assume that everybody else is that way as well.
这就是为什么我对说话的方式感到如此尴尬。因为我回家把一切都写了下来。这就是我的性格。我假设其他人也是这样。
We walk to the places that David likes best in Paris. And it's like hopping from one discreet island that David had already explored and found to be safe for human habitation to the next discreet island. I think this is the way that anybody gets to know any new city, especially a city where you do not speak the language. You try one place, and then you try a second place. And you return to those places over and over, slowly expanding your territory to gradually include more little spots that you return to.
我们走到戴维最喜欢的巴黎地方。这就像从一个戴维已经探索过、发现适合人类居住的安全小岛，跳到另一个安全小岛一样。我想这是任何人在熟悉任何新城市时所用的方式，特别是在一个不说当地语言的城市。你尝试一个地方，然后尝试第二个地方。你反复回到这些地方，缓慢地扩大你的领地，逐渐包括更多你会回去的小点。
The places David takes me to usually had one of these characteristics. There were fantastically unusual and interesting things to buy. They were places of a type which simply do not exist in the United States. And they were places where the French was usually very simple.
戴维带我去的那些地方通常具有以下特征之一：它们有极其不同寻常且有趣的商品；它们是在美国根本不存在的地方；而且在那些地方，法语通常非常简单。
(SUBJECT) PUPPETTER: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
(角色)木偶师：[法语对话]
[CHILDREN YELLING]
[孩子们叫喊声]
Often, this meant the presence of children. At the Luxembourg Gardens, there's an old puppet theater where we see Treasure of the Sultans. It's like watching an art form as sturdy and indestructible as the cockroach-- the slapstick, the menacing character sneaking up behind our heroes' backs so everybody yells in warning.
通常，这意味着有孩子在场。在卢森堡公园，有一个古老的木偶剧院，我们看到了《苏丹的宝藏》。这就像在看一种像蟑螂一样坚固且不可摧毁的艺术形式——滑稽动作、偷偷溜到英雄背后的险恶角色，于是每个人都在大声警告。
And there always comes a point where he hits somebody over the head with a stick. And the kids just eat it up. When he starts hitting people with the stick, they go bananas. This is the fourth time I've seen The Treasure of the Sultans. I just like coming because it just makes me so happy to be around people who are so happy.
总会有一个情节是他用棍子敲打别人的头。孩子们简直乐疯了。当他开始用棍子敲人时，他们就发疯了。这是我第四次看《苏丹的宝藏》。我喜欢来这里，因为能和那些如此快乐的人在一起，让我感到非常开心。
After the princess is safe from the pirates and the friendly tiger is rescued from the savage jungle to come live in Paris, we head outside to the carousel, where six-year-olds are strapped onto wooden horses and handed little wooden sticks, play a game that dates to 16th century Europe, or possibly earlier, a jousting game where they tried to spear a dangling ring while speeding by on horseback.
在公主从海盗手中脱险、友好的老虎从残酷的丛林中被救出并来到巴黎生活之后，我们前往外面的旋转木马，六岁的孩子们被绑在木马上，被递给小木棍，玩一个追溯到16世纪欧洲甚至更早的游戏——一种骑马飞驰时试图刺中悬挂圆环的打斗游戏。
[CHILD YELLING]
[孩子叫喊声]
David also takes me to one of the tiny mom-and-pop theaters in his neighborhood. The whole culture of movies is different in Paris, with hundreds of theaters showing all sorts of movies, new and old.
戴维还带我去了他附近的一家小型夫妻影院。整个巴黎的电影文化都很不同，有数百家剧院放映各种新老电影。
(SUBJECT) MOVIE CHARACTER 1: Nice little place you have here, Lydecker.
(角色)电影角色1：你这儿不错，莱德克。
(SUBJECT) MOVIE CHARACTER 2: It's lavish, but I call it home.
(角色)电影角色2：这很奢华，但我称之为家。
David sees a movie everyday in Paris. He also takes me to the flea market that's open every weekend on the outskirts of the city. It's a sprawling warren of booths selling old paintings, watches, and what amount to five centuries of coffee table decorations.
戴维在巴黎每天看一场电影。他还带我去了每周末都在城市郊区开放的跳蚤市场。这是一个庞大的摊位迷宫，出售古画、手表，以及五百年来咖啡桌上的装饰品。
We find a device in one store from the early days of telephones. It's just a paper cone, really, designed to be attached to a telephone inside a theater so your family at home could supposedly listen in on the concert or play over the telephone, in defiance, I might add, of all the principles of proper microphone placement. But that wasn't the highlight of our flea market trip.
我们在一家店里发现了一个来自早期电话时代的装置。它实际上只是一个纸锥，设计用于附在剧院内的电话上，这样你在家的家人就可以通过电话收听音乐会或戏剧——顺便说一下，这完全无视了所有正确放置麦克风的原则。但那不是我们跳蚤市场之行的重头戏。
Whereas most places here, people have their booth-- I was here the last shopping day before Christmas. Oh, my god. That's Judge Judy. That's Judge Judy with that white parka on. I love Judge Judy! And that was her right there!
而在大多数地方，人们有自己的摊位——圣诞节前的最后一个购物日我在这儿。天哪。那是朱迪法官。那是穿着白色派克大衣的朱迪法官。我爱朱迪法官！她就在那儿！
Should we say something?
我们要去打个招呼吗？
No. If you watch her show, you get the idea that saying something-- bothering somebody like that is so inappropriate. And that's what she does for a living, is tell people that they're acting inappropriately. I can't believe that we saw her. I love Judge Judy so much. I wish that she would run for mayor of New York. Wow, Judge Judy.
不。如果你看她的节目，你会觉得去打扰某人太不合适了。而这正是她赖以生存的事业：告诉人们他们的行为不合适。我不敢相信我们看到了她。我太爱朱迪法官了。我真希望她能竞选纽约市长。哇，朱迪法官。
Is that your biggest celebrity sighting in a while in Paris?
那是你最近在巴黎看到的最大牌明星吗？
I saw Catherine Deneuve. But Judge Judy is bigger than Catherine Deneuve, as far as I'm concerned. This square up here, this is the Pantheon.
我见过凯瑟琳·德纳芙。但对我而言，朱迪法官比凯瑟琳·德纳芙更大牌。上面的这个广场，这是万神殿。
And again, I've never been inside of it. But I know that all kinds of famous French people are entombed here. I don't know. I think Balzac's here or people like that, really super famous writers. But I've never set foot inside. But I like the frozen grocery store that's across the street from it.
同样，我从来没进去过。但我知道各种著名的法国人都埋葬在这里。我不知道。我想巴尔扎克在这里，或者类似的人，超级伟大的作家。但我从没踏进去过。但我喜欢马路对面那家冷冻杂货店。
This store is part of a chain that's all over France called Picard. Everything they sell is frozen.
这家店是法国连锁店Picard的一部分。他们卖的所有东西都是冷冻的。
And they've got this method for freezing that I don't think we have in the United States. They could freeze lettuce. And they've got everything in there, from meat to frozen soups and spices.
他们有一种我们美国可能没有的冷冻方法。他们可以冷冻生菜。他们店里什么都有，从肉类到冷冻汤和香料。
But it's not like TV dinners. You can buy a little packet of ostrich chops, or of horse meat, or duck legs stuffed with prunes and sausage. And they're sold just in plastic bags. So they've taken the stigma out of frozen food.
但这不像冷冻晚餐。你可以买到一小包鸵鸟排、马肉，或者塞了西梅和香肠的鸭腿。它们只是用塑料袋装的。所以他们去掉了冷冻食品的污名。
And every French person I've talked to swears by this store, especially people who have kids. Because the food is really, really good. And if you opened one of these in the United States, you would just be minting money.
我交谈过的每一个法国人都对这家店赞不绝口，特别是家里有孩子的人。因为食物真的、真的很好。如果你在美国开一家这样的店，你简直就是在印钞票。
You wouldn't be able to count the money fast enough. I guarantee you. It would be such a huge success.
你根本来不及数钱。我保证。它会取得巨大的成功。
Inside, it is exactly what you want when you're traveling in a foreign country. Every object is familiar, but packaged and presented in a way that is pleasingly new and exotic. So it's all comprehensible but, at the same time, palpably foreign.
走进店里，这正是你在国外旅行时想要的感觉。每一件物品都很熟悉，但包装和呈现方式却令人愉快地新鲜和异国情调。所以这一切都能理解，但同时，它又确实是外来的。
And the foods walk that disturbing but fascinating line that foreign foods can have between looking delicious and looking frightening-- snails packed in green stuff in their shells of many different sizes, coolers full of massive frozen crayfish that look like they're about to come back to life, pre-made shish kabobs, osso buco. We pick up a few things. And then down the hill, we stop at the regular supermarket for a quick run to the dairy case.
那些食物走在令人不安但又迷人的界限上，在异国食品中往往会有，介于看起来美味和看起来令人恐惧之间——壳里塞满了绿色调料的各种大小的蜗牛，冷藏柜里装满了巨大的冷冻小龙虾，看起来仿佛要活过来，预制烤肉串，炖牛膝。我们买了一些东西。然后下山，我们在普通的超市停下来，快速逛了一下乳制品区。
Hugh screamed at me last night, he was so ashamed of the butter that we served during dinner. And he held this brand of butter right up to my face and told me I'm never, ever, ever allowed to buy it again. So I'm here to replace that butter.
休昨晚对我大吼，因为我们晚餐时上的黄油让他感到太丢脸了。他把这个品牌的黄油直接举到我脸上，告诉我永远、永远、永远不允许再买它了。所以我来这儿换那个黄油。
Wait, what kind of butter did you buy?
等等，你买了什么黄油？
It was this, but it's Grand Jury brand, a butter of Brittany. And I'm not allowed to buy that anymore.
是这个，但这叫“大陪审团”品牌，是布列塔尼的黄油。我不允许再买那个了。
Why?
为什么？
Because Hugh's really picky about things like that. He said, I saw Ira putting that butter on bread, and he had four pieces of bread. I'm so embarrassed. That butter was awful.
因为休对那种事情很挑剔。他说：“我看到艾拉把那种黄油涂在面包上，他拿了四片面包。我太尴尬了。那黄油太糟糕了。”
And I said, I don't really think that Ira's going to go home and write in his little notebook, dinner at Hugh and David's, butter was terrible.
我说：“我不觉得艾拉会回家在他的小笔记本里写：‘在休和戴维家晚餐，黄油很难吃。’”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
That's where you're wrong, my friend.
那你就错了，朋友。
Note to listeners-- if you eat at Hugh and David's, avoid the butter.
给听众的提示：如果你在休和戴维家吃饭，请避开那份黄油。
[FOOTSTEPS]
[脚步声]
At 31 Rue du Bac, we climb a wooden spiral staircase to a store that's been in operation since 1831, Deyrolle, which David calls the Noah's ark of taxidermy.
在巴克街31号，我们爬上一段木质旋转楼梯，来到一家自1831年起就开始营业的店——Deyrolle，戴维称之为“动物标本界的诺亚方舟”。
There's a kangaroo. There's a moose. There's two wild boars.
有一只袋鼠。有一头驼鹿。有两头野猪。
There's about five different varieties of monkeys, a hyena, a pair of zebras, a polar bear, and a beautiful oak case containing different reptiles-- snakes and lizards. And there's an ostrich. And that ostrich is-- what-- nine feet tall. It's really magnificent.
大约有五种不同品种的猴子、一只鬣狗、一对斑马、一只北极熊，还有一个美丽的橡木箱，里面装着不同的爬行动物——蛇和蜥蜴。还有一只鸵鸟。那只鸵鸟——什么——有九英尺高。它真的非常壮观。
We walk through room after room filled with pigs and lions, cats and dogs. The dogs are especially real looking. Some of them, according to the woman who runs the place, were stuffed by their owners, but they never had the heart to pick them up. The price to buy an ostrich or a lion or gorilla is nearly $10,000. To rent them for two days is 420 bucks, American. Most of the business is rental. David buys a magpie, black and powerful and sleek-looking, and we had down to the street.
我们穿过一个又一个充满猪、狮子、猫和狗的房间。那些狗看起来特别真实。据经营这家店的女人说，其中一些是由它们的主人制作成标本的，但他们一直没有勇气来取回。买一只鸵鸟、狮子或大猩猩的价格接近1万美元。租用两天是420美元。大部分生意都是租赁。戴维买了一只喜鹊，黑色、有力且看起来线条流畅，我们走下街头。
So did you have things like this when you were a kid?
你小时候有这样的东西吗？
My mother had a great aunt who was the only person in our family who really had any money. And she was married to a man who was a big game hunter. And she would come to our house to visit when we were young.
我母亲的一位大姨是我们家族中唯一真正有钱的人。她嫁给了一个大猎手。我们小的时候她会来我们家做客。
But I only went to her house once. And it was right before she died. And she had a trophy room. And there were all kinds of animals in there, extinct animals. There were snow leopards in there. There were white tigers in there.
但我只去过她家一次。那是在她去世前不久。她有一个战利品室。里面有各种各样的动物，灭绝的动物。里面有雪豹。里面有白虎。
And you would walk into this perfect room, and there were thousands of eyes staring at you. And I just thought, this is what I want. And that's the thing that I loved. And that's the feeling you get when you go into Deyolle, that all of these creatures that are stuffed and poised to pounce are all staring at you. It's the same feeling you get from being in front of an audience.
你会走进这个完美的房间，有成千上万双眼睛盯着你。我心想：“这就是我想要的。”这就是我热爱的东西。这就是当你走进Deyrolle时那种感觉，所有的这些生物都做成了标本，摆出扑击的姿态，全都盯着你。这和你站在观众面前得到的感觉是一样的。
It's the same feeling you get in front of an audience?
和你站在观众面前得到的感觉一样？
Yeah, that people are looking at you. But these are creatures that are looking at you.
是的，人们在看着你。但这些是盯着你看的生物。
Wow.
哇。
You know that feeling, that feeling when somebody is watching you.
你知道那种感觉，当有人在注视着你的时候。
David, of course, thinks about that feeling a lot, especially here in France, where he wonders what Parisians think as they watch him speaking so badly. But it's not entirely so hard, that daily stage fright, worrying about how to say every little thing, anxious and straining to understand all the words around him.
戴维当然经常思考那种感觉，特别是在法国，他好奇当他说话如此糟糕时巴黎人会怎么想。但那并不完全那么艰难，那种每日的舞台恐惧，担心如何说出每一件小事，焦虑且费力地理解周围所有的词语。
It's that thinking that makes me feel alive and that makes me notice everything around me. When I become complacent, like I was in the United States, you just get used to things, so you don't think about them. You think, I'll get a cab. I'll go to the airport. I'll have a patty melt. And you don't think about it.
正是那种思考让我感到活着，让我注意到周围的一切。当我变得自满时，就像我在美国那样，你只是习惯了这些事情，所以你不会去思考它们。你会想：“我会打车。我会去机场。我会去吃一个肉饼三明治。”你根本不会去想它。
Whereas now, with me, the anxiety starts early on. And I'm always afraid that someone's going to throw me a curveball and ask me a question, like, what sign are you? They'll just ask me a question like that out of nowhere, and I'll appear foolish. So it keeps me on edge. But really, that edginess has always made me feel alive.
而现在，对我来说，焦虑很早就开始了。我总是害怕有人会给我扔一个“曲线球”，问我一个问题，比如：“你是什么星座的？”他们会冷不丁地问出这样的问题，而我会显得很愚蠢。所以它让我保持紧张。但真的，那种紧张感一直让我感到活着。
Someday, David says, he'll be more comfortable in French. His accent will improve and that daily anxiety will be removed from his life.
戴维说，总有一天，他在法语方面会更自如。他的口音会提高，那种日常的焦虑会从他的生活中移除。
But when it is removed from me, then I probably won't be interested in living here anymore. I'll probably leave.
但当它被移除时，我可能就不想住在这里了。我可能会离开。
Because it'll be just like living back home.
因为它会变得像回到家一样。
Plus the more you learn, the more disappointed you wind up being. It's easy to like somebody when you don't know what they're saying.
加上你学得越多，最终就越会感到失望。当你不知道别人在说什么时，很容易喜欢上一个人。
That's interesting. I hadn't thought about that, that not understanding somebody makes them seem more interesting than they really are.
这很有意思。我没想过那个，不理解一个人会让对方看起来比实际更有趣。
I just assume that everyone talked about books and movies all the time. That's all they talked about, as far as I was concerned. And then I learned a little bit more and I realized that they're no different than the people anywhere else, that they talk about the same banal things that we all talk about everywhere.
我只是假设每个人一直在讨论书和电影。就我所知，他们讨论的都是那些。然后我了解得更多了一点，我意识到他们和任何地方的人都没有什么不同，他们谈论的都是我们到处都在谈论的那些陈词滥调。
At one point, at the cafe David goes to all the time, we sit and watch a waiter that David likes to watch, though he barely dares to say a word to him. The waiter's in his mid-40's with a kind, baggy face. Picture the actor who played the scarecrow in The Wizard of Oz, Ray Bolger.
有一次，在戴维经常去的咖啡馆，我们坐着看一个戴维喜欢观察的服务员，尽管他几乎不敢对他说一个字。服务员大约40多岁，有着一张友善、松弛的脸。想象一下《绿野仙踪》里扮演稻草人的演员，雷·波尔格。
And this waiter's kind of a cut-up. He hangs out with the regulars, making them laugh at this and that. That's what makes him fun to watch.
这位服务员是个滑稽的人。他和常客混在一起，让他们为这或那而发笑。这就是他看起来有趣的原因。
You wonder, though, where that guy lives, or how much money he makes, or if he's married. You know, you don't wonder about everybody. But I've always wondered about that guy. Do you think he makes his bed?
不过你会好奇，那家伙住在哪里，他挣多少钱，或者他是否结婚了。你知道，你不会对每个人都好奇。但我一直对那个人很好奇。你觉得他会铺床吗？
For now, things are good for David in Paris. He still feels curious about everything, about figuring out what it all means. And that makes everything so interesting all the time. The mystery has not ebbed from everyday life. Ray Bolger takes a sip of wine.
目前，戴维在巴黎过得很好。他仍然对一切感到好奇，好奇一切意味着什么。这让一切一直都非常有趣。神秘感还没有从日常生活中褪去。雷·波尔格啜饮了一口酒。
I always like it, too, when people drink on the job. He's behind a bar, he's drinking wine, he's smoking a cigarette, and he's picking his nose, which are three good reasons to live in France, I think.
我也一直很喜欢人们在工作中喝酒。他站在吧台后面，他在喝酒，他在抽烟，而且他在挖鼻孔，我认为这是住在法国的三个好理由。
David Sedaris. His book about Paris is called "Me Talk Pretty One Day." His latest book is "Calypso."
戴维·塞达里斯。他那本关于巴黎的书叫《我在巴黎的羞耻日子》（Me Talk Pretty One Day）。他最新的书是《卡里普索》。
[MUSIC - LLOYD COLE, "SI TU DOIS PARTIR"]
[音乐 - 劳埃德·科尔，“如果你必须离开”]
Coming up, a public radio host who does not speak French mangles more foreign words in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，一位不会说法语的公共广播主持人将在一分钟内继续糟蹋更多的外语词汇。来自芝加哥公共广播电台，节目继续。
I'm Ira Glass. It's This American Life, the radio program that dares to ask the question--
我是艾拉·格拉斯。这里是《美国生活》，敢于提出那个问题的广播节目——
(SUBJECT) CHOIR: (SINGING) Parlez-vous francais?
(合唱团)：(唱)会说法语吗？
No, after you, madame. If I can lay my cards on the table at this point in the program, I have never understood why anybody cares so much about France. I mean, it's fine. It's lovely.
不，你先请，女士。如果我可以在节目的这一点上摊牌的话，我从来不明白为什么有人对法国如此着迷。我的意思是，这很好。很可爱。
But there is just this thing that some Americans have for Paris. Though, as they are the first to admit, it can be kind of ridiculous.
但有些美国人对巴黎确实有这种迷恋。尽管，正如他们首先承认的那样，这可能有点可笑。
Well, when people ask me where I live, I sometimes say Paris. And they say, well, you live in Paris? But that's my dream.
好吧，当人们问我住在哪里时，我有时会说巴黎。他们会说：“什么？你住在巴黎？那是我的梦想。”
Kristin Hohenadel has lived in Paris for five years.
克里斯汀·霍恩阿德尔在巴黎住了五年。
Why do you live in Paris? And I say, well, I just sort of wanted to. All the reasons that you would give sound really embarrassing, cliche, and ridiculous at this point. Paris is a stale dream.
“你为什么住巴黎？”我说：“好吧，我只是想住。”在这个阶段，你给出的所有理由听起来都非常尴尬、陈词滥调且荒谬。巴黎是一个陈旧的梦想。
And it's kind of like falling in love with the most obviously cute boy in the class, or a movie star. It's like being a groupie. And then you try to convince the other 25 women who he slept with last week, well, I really love him, and I think he loves me too.
这有点像爱上了班上最显而易见的可爱男生，或者电影明星。这就像成为一个狂热粉丝。然后你试着去说服其他25个他上周睡过的女人：“好吧，我真的很爱他，而且我觉得他也爱我。”
There are some people who come here and they sort of get off on that feeling of being-- they think they're unusual because they put themselves in this position. And to me, that's really kind of awful and embarrassing.
有些人来到这里，他们从那种感觉中获得快感——他们觉得自己与众不同，因为他们把自己置于这个位置。对我来说，这真的很可怕且令人尴尬。
They think they're really special.
他们觉得自己真的很特别。
Yeah. They think it makes them special to live here, A, as if it's original. And B, part of the horrifying thing about moving here is it's a sort of disappointing experience to realize that your dream is so banal.
是的。他们认为住在这里让他们显得很特别，A，好像这是原创的。而且B，搬到这里的一个可怕之处在于，意识到你的梦想是如此平庸，这是一种令人失望的体验。
This is a dream I had my whole life. And it seems ridiculous to me now that it meant so much to me. It was so important.
这是我一生的梦想。而它曾经对我意味着那么多，现在对我来说看起来很荒谬。那太重要了。
The thing about loving a city, Kristin says, is that a city doesn't really love you back. Whenever I asked Americans who love France what it was about France that just got to them so much-- when did it begin for them, their feeling about France-- they all talked about scraps of French culture that made it to them when they were very young-- the Madeline books, The Red Balloon, French films, Montessori French class in grade school. I think there is still a part of America where the idea of Paris-- Paris, not the space program, or the internet, or moving to New York City-- Paris represents reaching a world outside oneself.
克里斯汀说，热爱一座城市的事情在于，城市并不真正爱你。每当我问热爱法国的美国人，到底是什么关于法国让他们如此着迷——当他们对法国的感觉刚开始时——他们都谈到了当他们很小的时候接触到的那些法国文化碎片——玛德琳书、红气球、法国电影、小学里的蒙台梭利法语课。我想在美国仍然有一部分，关于巴黎的想法——巴黎，不是空间计划，或者互联网，或者搬到纽约市——巴黎代表着触及自身之外的世界。
Richard Klein first started coming here as a teenager from a small town in Pennsylvania and has essentially constructed an entire life around the feeling that he got in Paris. He went on to become a scholar and director of the Romance Studies department at Cornell University and author of several books, Eat Fat and Cigarettes Are Sublime, which are deeply suffused with a sensibility that is partly just un-American or, anyway, semi-Parisian, a sensibility that is all about the small pleasures of everyday life.
理查德·克莱因第一次作为来自宾夕法尼亚州一个小镇的青少年来到这里，并且基本围绕他在巴黎得到的那种感觉构建了整个生活。他后来成为康奈尔大学罗曼语言学系的主任，并著有几本书，《吃脂肪》和《香烟是崇高的》，这些书中深深渗透了一种部分地只是非美国化，或者无论如何是半巴黎化的感受，一种全关于日常生活中小小快乐的感受。
You know, the French have a much more uncomplicated and much less guilty relationship to their body, beginning with eating, not only the way they eat, the pleasure that they take in eating. The American notion that food is medicine, for example, is totally repulsive to the French. And yet increasingly, in America, that's all you hear. People eat only as a function of what they think is good for them. And nobody in France would eat strictly as a function of what's good for them.
你知道，法国人与他们身体的关系要简单得多，愧疚感也少得多，从饮食开始，不仅仅是他们吃饭的方式，还有他们在饮食中获得的快乐。例如，美国认为食物是药物的观念，对法国人来说是完全令人反感的。然而在美国，你听到的越来越多都是这个。人们吃饭仅仅是出于他们认为对他们好的功能。而在法国，没有人会仅仅为了对身体好的功能而吃饭。
I'll tell you, I think really the heart of it, for me, when I came here in 1958 for the first time, was Les Halles. Les Halles was the central marketplace right in the heart of Paris, not far from where we are. And I remember I used to go there not every night but frequently.
我告诉你，对我来说，1958年我第一次来到这里时，真正的核心是Les Halles。Les Halles是位于巴黎中心地带的中央市场，离我们现在的地方不远。我记得我经常去那里，不是每天晚上，但很频繁。
And then, at around 2:00 in the morning, you would go out in the streets in Les Halles, which was the central marketplace. And they used to bring all the food every night. Trucks would bring the produce and food from all over France to the center of Paris, to the heart of Paris, and display it in the stalls all around the streets.
然后，在大约凌晨2点，你会走到Les Halles的街上，那是中央市场。他们每晚都会把所有的食物运过来。卡车会从法国各地把农产品和食物运到巴黎中心，运到巴黎心脏地带，并把它们展示在街道各处的摊位里。
Butchers were there with their blood-splattered coats. And people made gorgeous piles of artichokes and carrots and cabbages. And it was 2:00 in the morning and it was like life was just beginning at that hour.
屠夫们穿着沾满血迹的围裙在那里。人们把朝鲜蓟、胡萝卜和卷心菜堆成美丽的堆。那是凌晨2点，在这个小时里，生活仿佛才刚刚开始。
And people were there sort of buying and selling. And then right next to Les Halles was La Rue Saint-Denis. And La Rue Saint-Denis was the center of prostitution in Paris.
人们在那里进行着买卖。而Les Halles旁边就是圣丹尼斯街。圣丹尼斯街是巴黎卖淫活动的中心。
And the people who worked there would work until 4:00 or 5:00 in the morning, and then they would visit the prostitutes who were there all night. But this world of-- I don't know-- this incredible life, and food, and sex, and beauty in the middle of one of the most beautiful parts and oldest parts of the past-- it used to be until the 19th century that the biggest cemetery was right there in Paris.
在那里工作的人会工作到凌晨4点或5点，然后他们会去见整晚都在那里的妓女。但这个世界——我不知道——这种不可思议的生活、食物、性和美丽，就在过去最美丽、最古老的部分之中——直到19世纪，最大的公墓就在巴黎那里。
If you walk around Paris with Richard, he's constantly pointing out spots that had special meaning to Louis XIV. Or there's a restaurant that happened to be one of the first restaurants ever built in France, just after they began the idea of restaurants, or the shops where the notion of putting big, huge windows on the front of stores probably began so people could window shop. The fact is, a lot of what is so pleasing about being in Paris is simple. It's a really interesting, pleasing place just to walk around.
如果你和理查德在巴黎到处走，他会不断指出那些对路易十四有特殊意义的地点。或者有一家餐厅碰巧是法国建造的第一批餐厅之一，就在他们开始有餐厅概念后不久，或者那些商店，在商店前面安装巨大橱窗的观念可能就是从那里开始的，这样人们就可以逛橱窗了。事实是，在巴黎生活最令人愉悦的很多东西都很简单。它是一个非常有趣、令人愉悦的地方，仅仅是到处逛逛而已。
When Kristin Hohenadel tried last year to live back in the States again, she found she missed living in Paris. She missed all that. It'd be kind of hard to get ordinary things done in France. You're always kind of an outsider here, even after years in the country. But she just feels better here.
去年，当克里斯汀·霍恩阿德尔尝试搬回美国生活时，她发现她想念住在巴黎的日子。她想念这一切。在法国处理普通事务可能有点困难。你在这里总是某种局外人，即使在法国住了多年。但她觉得在这里感觉更好。
You know, you walk down the street in Los Angeles-- and it's a terrible example, because it's Los Angeles-- but you feel kind of dwarfed. And here, I just think, yes, this is exactly it. This is how life should be-- the pace, the scale, the way it looks.
你知道，你在洛杉矶的街上走——这是一个糟糕的例子，因为那是洛杉矶——但你会觉得自己有点矮小。而在这里，我只是想：“是的，这就是它。生活本该如此——节奏、规模、看起来的样子。”
[MUSIC - BLOSSOM DEARIE, "COMMENT ALLEZ-VOUS?"]
[音乐 - 布洛瑟姆·迪瑞，“你好吗？”]
Act three, "Notes of a Native Daughter." Janet McDonald had already learned the language. She'd already learned the culture, had French friends and a French apartment, when something happened that made her realize how much she hadn't figured out.
第三幕，“一位本土女儿的笔记”。珍妮特·麦克唐纳已经学会了这门语言。她已经学会了这种文化，有了法国朋友和巴黎公寓，当时发生了一件事，让她意识到她自己还没有搞明白多少东西。
I was going to the movies with a friend of mine from Yale who is black also. And there was a long line. And we were like, let's jump the line.
我和一个耶鲁的朋友去电影院，她也是黑人。队伍很长。我们想：“去排队吧。”
These white people, they're going to be scared of us. We'll just go and jump the line. We'll get to the front of the line.
“这些白人，他们会害怕我们的。我们要去排队。我们要排到队伍的最前面。”
So of course, we walked up to the front of the line, like, yeah, you want to try me? I'm black. That usually works in New York.
当然，我们走到队伍前面，心想：“是啊，想挑战我吗？我是黑人。”这在纽约通常有效。
These people were ready to rip our hair out. And they were white. I couldn't believe it.
这些人准备把我们的头发撕下来。而且他们是白人。我不敢相信。
And they were like, in French, what are you doing? The line starts back there! You can't just walk to the front of the line!
他们用法语说：“你们在干什么？队伍从后面开始！你们不能直接走到队首！”
They were ready to kick our butts. I was shocked. I'm like, these are white people and they're not scared of us? [LAUGHS]
他们准备踢我们的屁股。我震惊了。我说：“这些是白人，他们不害怕我们？”[笑]
That's when I realized I wasn't in Kansas anymore. And I liked it. Of course, it was kind of humiliating, because we're supposed to be the intimidating, scary ones. And then all these like French bitches in high heels are threatening us, and they were in our faces. [LAUGHS] And it made me realize that whole black-white game just doesn't work outside of the United States.
就在那时我意识到我不在堪萨斯了。我喜欢它。当然，那有点羞辱感，因为我们应该是那个令人生畏、可怕的角色。结果所有这些穿着高跟鞋的法国碧池威胁我们，她们就在我们脸上。[笑] 这让我意识到，整个黑白游戏在美国之外根本行不通。
Because white people aren't afraid of you here. And at the same time, they don't hate you. Because that sort of goes together.
因为白人在这里不怕你。同时，他们也不恨你。因为那通常是一起发生的。
So I'll take it. I'll wait on line. Now I don't dare jump lines. [LAUGHS] So that opened my eyes.
所以我接受。我会排队。现在我不敢加塞了。[笑] 所以那让我大开眼界。
Janet and I are sitting in the Cafe Flore, one of those famous and corniest and most pretentious settings in which to meet, because it and the Deux Magots cafe next door were home to Sartre, and Camus, and Simone de Beauvoir, and, when he first arrived in Paris in 1946, Richard Wright, who was well known by them as the author of Black Boy and Native Son.
我和珍妮特坐在花神咖啡馆，这是那种见面最著名、最俗气、最装腔作势的场所之一，因为这里和隔壁的双偶咖啡馆曾是萨特、加缪、西蒙娜·德·波伏娃的家，当理查德·赖特1946年刚到巴黎时，他也常去，他被他们熟知为《土生子》和《黑孩子》的作者。
Now it's sort of a gathering place for tourists, and wannabes, and nostalgic fake French people such as myself.
现在它算是一个游客、想成为那种人的人以及像我这样的怀旧假法国人的聚集地。
It's classic old cafe on a corner with aging fixtures and plate glass windows onto the street. Lovely, but not ornate. By the time Richard Wright arrived here, Josephine Baker had come, seen, and conquered. Black GIs had come and conquered. Jazz had simply conquered.
这是转角处经典的旧咖啡馆，有着老化的设施和通向街道的平板玻璃窗。可爱，但不华丽。当理查德·赖特来到这里时，约瑟芬·贝克已经来了，看到了，征服了。黑人美国大兵来了，征服了。爵士乐也已经征服了一切。
Wright wrote in a letter, "There's such an absence of race hatred. It seems a little unreal." I wanted to talk to Janet, because I wanted to find out if it was still that way for blacks in Paris. It didn't seem possible, really.
赖特在信中写道：“种族仇恨如此匮乏。这看起来有点不真实。”我想和珍妮特谈谈，因为我想找出对于黑人来说，现在的巴黎是否依然如此。这看起来似乎不太可能。
In the half-century since those days, there's been an influx of black Africans to France. And they are not beloved. National Front party, with the slogan "France is for the French," wins 15% of the vote in national elections. Could it be possible that African-Americans still get a warm reception here? Janet said yes.
在那之后的半个世纪里，大量的非洲黑人涌入了法国。他们并不受爱戴。拥有“法国是法国人的”口号的国民阵线党在全国选举中赢得了15%的选票。非裔美国人在这里仍然能得到热情接待，这可能吗？珍妮特说可以。
I'm not sure what it is. All I know is that it feels very different to be around French white people than American white people.
我不确定这是什么。我只知道，和法国白人在一起的感觉比和美国白人在一起感觉非常不同。
Different how?
不同在哪里？
I feel much more comfortable. I feel that I'm not a black object.
我感觉舒服多了。我觉得我不再是一个“黑人对象”。
Richard Wright, after arriving here in the mid-1940s, said that he felt that, all of his life, he'd been carrying a corpse with him. And when he came to Paris, he felt it slip off his back. Did you have that kind of feeling?
理查德·赖特在20世纪40年代中期到达这里后说，他觉得他一生都带着一具尸体。当他来到巴黎时，他觉得它从他的背上滑落了。你有那种感觉吗？
Yeah. I really have to say that I have felt that way ever since I got here. And a lot of my friends say, why are you living there? In fact, a friend of mine I went to law school with, he said, what is it about speaking French that makes white people not racist? He was very skeptical.
是的。我真的必须说，自从我来到这里，我就一直有那种感觉。我的很多朋友说：“你为什么要住在那里？”事实上，我法学院的一个朋友说：“说法语到底有什么特别的，让白人不再种族歧视了？”他非常怀疑。
But really, it goes beyond that. And it's not just that we feel free of the burden of race. Because we're still black.
但这确实超越了那个。不仅仅是我们感到摆脱了种族的重负。因为我们依然是黑人。
I still experience myself as black. It's just that that's not the center of my identity. It's not the first thing people relate to when I meet them here.
我仍然体验着自己是黑人。只是这不是我身份的核心。当我在这里见到人们时，这不是他们联系的第一件事。
Janet first came to Paris in 1975 and moved here in '95. She's a lawyer in the French office of a big American company. She grew up in the public housing projects in Brooklyn, worked her way into Vassar College and onto graduate school and law school. And like a lot of people who make the jump from very poor, crime-ridden neighborhoods into the college-educated upper middle class, she felt like she didn't really fit in anywhere, not with family and friends in the projects who were shooting heroin, barely surviving, not with the black students she met in college.
珍妮特1975年第一次来巴黎，95年搬到这里。她是一家大美国公司法国分部的律师。她在布鲁克林的公共住房项目长大，靠自己进入瓦萨学院，然后攻读研究生和法学院。像很多从非常贫穷、犯罪猖獗的街区跳进受过大学教育的受过教育的上中产阶级的人一样，她觉得她哪里都格格不入，无论是和在项目里的家人和朋友——他们在注射海洛因，勉强生存——还是和她在大学里遇到的黑人学生。
I thought they were Bourgeois southern belles. I didn't want to be anything like them. And they didn't want to be like me either. They thought I was trash.
我觉得她们是资产阶级南方美人。我不想像她们那样。她们也不想像我。她们觉得我是垃圾。
I was project trash. I thought they put the B in bougie. And so I grappled a lot with the racial identity.
我是项目垃圾。我觉得她们在“布尔乔亚”里加了个“B”。所以我对种族认同纠结了很多。
What will my posture be? I'm from the projects, but people say I talk like a white girl. And then the white girls are like, oh, you're so project.
我的姿态会是什么样？我来自项目，但人们说我说话像个白人女孩。然后白人女孩会说：“哦，你太项目了。”
And then when I got here, none of it mattered. Because if I spoke three words of French that made sense, people liked me and they celebrated me. So I didn't have to worry about talking like a white girl, or a project girl, or anything.
然后当我来到这里，这一切都不重要了。因为如果我能说出三句有意义的法语，人们就喜欢我，庆祝我。所以我不用担心说话像个白人女孩，或者项目女孩，或其他什么。
It was an incredible relief. The central conflict of her life suddenly vanished. In Paris, all the distinctions about what kind of black person she should be, they were all moot. In fact, the most distinguishing fact about Janet was not that she was black. It was that she was an American, which surprised her.
这是一种不可思议的解脱。她人生中的核心冲突突然消失了。在巴黎，所有关于她应该成为什么样黑人的区别，全都不重要了。事实上，关于珍妮特最显著的事实不是她是黑人。而是她是美国人，这让她很惊讶。
I associated the word American with white guys with flags on their lawns who didn't particularly like me. And people would call me American. And I'd say, I'm not American. I'm black.
我把“美国人”这个词和那些草坪上插着国旗、不太喜欢我的白人男性联系在一起。然后人们会叫我美国人。我说：“我不是美国人。我是黑人。”
And these were black French people. And they were like, you are so American. And I remember these French West Indian friends of mine-- this one in particular from Martinique-- saying, you even walk like an American.
而这些人是黑人法国人。他们说：“你太美国了。”我记得这些法国西印度群岛的朋友——这个特别来自马提尼克——说：“你走路的样子甚至都像个美国人。”
I'm like, what do you mean? What does an American walk like? And she said, they kick their legs when they walk. They kick their legs forward.
我说：“你什么意思？美国人走路是什么样？”她说：“他们走路时踢腿。他们把腿向前踢。”
I don't know. Because I was in Brooklyn just a few weeks ago. And this woman who'd never been to Europe was saying, so what's it like in France? What are the people like? Are they prejudiced?
我不知道。因为几周前我在布鲁克林。这个从没去过欧洲的女人说：“法国是什么样？那里的人怎么样？他们有偏见吗？”
I said, no, they like us. It's incredible-- a country full of white people and they like us. But it's a difficult thing, because they like us, but they don't like other people who look like us. And that's sort of the French paradox.
我说：“不，他们喜欢我们。这简直难以置信——一个住满白人的国家，而他们喜欢我们。”但这是一件困难的事，因为他们喜欢我们，但他们不喜欢看起来像我们的人。而这大概就是法国悖论。
Paris, of course, has its own housing projects in the suburbs that surround the city. Now, with generations of Africans who were born on French soil, they face job discrimination, housing discrimination.
巴黎当然有自己环绕城市的郊区住宅区。现在，随着在法国土地上出生的非洲后裔，他们面临就业歧视、住房歧视。
And they're not well received. They're not welcomed. And they are French.
他们不受欢迎。他们不被接纳。而他们是法国人。
And so in a way, for African-Americans, we're in a very bizarre position. It's almost like being an honorary white in apartheid South Africa. And I noticed that, as my French got better and better, sometimes I wasn't as well received as I would be if I played up my American accent. If I walked into a shop, and people would think I was just basically-- what I say-- just another [BLEEP], just like one of their own, like from Martinique or Guadalupe, it wouldn't be the same reception if I came on with a very heavy American accent or even spoke English.
所以某种程度上，对于非裔美国人，我们处在一个非常古怪的位置。这简直就像在种族隔离时期的南非做一个“荣誉白人”。我注意到，随着我的法语变得越来越好，有时我受到的接待不如我强调美国口音那样好。如果我走进一家店，人们认为我基本上只是——我说——只是另一个[哔]，就像他们自己人，比如来自马提尼克或瓜德罗普，那受到的待遇肯定不如我带着非常浓重的美国口音、甚至说英语时那样。
Why? How would they treat you if they thought you were an African black?
为什么？如果他们认为你是非洲黑人，他们会怎么对待你？
A little bit of a chill in the air, like, yes, may I help you? Not so much, oh, vous etes Americaine! Oh, I love New York! I love to speak English!
空气中会有一点寒意，比如：“是的，我可以帮你吗？”而不是那种：“哦，你是美国人！哦，我爱纽约！我爱说英语！”
So it's very bizarre. It's a hard thing to reconcile. Because good feeling is good feeling. And when someone receives you and makes you feel good, it's a positive experience.
所以这非常古怪。这是一件很难调和的事情。因为好感觉就是好感觉。当有人接纳你并让你感觉良好时，这是一种积极的体验。
When you're in a shop, and you can feel that there's a chill in the air, and that they think of you as an African, will you actually play up your American accent?
当你在店里时，你能感觉到空气中有寒意，他们把你当作非洲人看待，你会真的刻意加强你的美国口音吗？
Well, what happened was I started experiencing that. And so I actually adjusted my speech so that at least I would get the benefit of-- I mean, I'm here in this country. I want to get the benefit of being an African-American.
好吧，发生的事情是我开始经历那种事情。所以我实际上调整了我的说话方式，至少我能得到好处——我的意思是，我住在这个国家。我想得到身为非裔美国人的好处。
So instead of walking in-- oui, madame, [SPEAKING FRENCH], I'd say, oui, [SPEAKING FRENCH]. [LAUGHS]
所以与其走进去说——“Oui，女士，[法语对话]”，我会说“Oui，[法语对话]”。[笑]
Maybe I shouldn't do that.
也许我不该那样做。
And it works?
而且那有效吗？
Yeah, and it works.
是的，它有效。
A friend of Janet's suggested to her that maybe Parisians prefer black people from America because only a certain class of black Americans usually comes to France-- educated, cultured, interested in France. When Janet asked the writer Cornel West about this at a speech he gave this summer in Paris, that was his argument.
珍妮特的一个朋友建议她，也许巴黎人更喜欢来自美国的黑人，因为通常只有特定阶层的美国黑人会来法国——受过教育、有文化、对法国感兴趣。当珍妮特今年夏天在巴黎的一个演讲中问作家康奈尔·韦斯特这个问题时，那是他的观点。
Basically, he suggested it was a class thing. And he said, well, look at you. You're professional. You're articulate. Maybe if you brought 15 of your cousins, it would be a whole different thing.
基本上，他暗示这是一种阶级问题。他说：“看看你自己。你是专业人士。你谈吐清晰。也许如果你带上你的15个堂兄弟，情况就会完全不同了。”
So basically he was saying, if I brought all my homegirls from the hood who didn't go to Vassar, and who weren't lawyers, and who didn't speak French, the reception might be a little chillier, even though they also are black American. But I think, if that's true, that is not about racism. Then that's about class.
所以基本上他说的是，如果我带上所有那些没去过瓦萨、不是律师、不会说法语的贫民窟女孩，接待可能会稍微冷淡一点，尽管她们也是美国黑人。但我认为，如果那是真的，那与种族主义无关。那与阶级有关。
Before I met Janet, I read the book that she wrote about what it was like for her growing up. It's called Project Girl. And what's remarkable about it is how frank she is about all of the compulsive things that she found herself doing during the years that she was regularly traveling between the projects and the world of the aspiring upper middle class. It was a struggle.
在见到珍妮特之前，我读了她写的关于她成长经历的书。那叫《项目女孩》。令人惊叹的是她对自己在那几年里定期往返于贫民窟项目和上中产阶级世界之间时发现自己必须做的所有强迫性事情有多坦率。那是一场斗争。
In her first year at Vassar, for instance, she felt so out of place that she started taking the train down to New York City to score heroin, a thing she'd never even done when she lived in the projects, until she got kicked out of school for that. It was as if the further that she traveled into the world of college, the more the project side of her personality was compelled to express itself somehow. She depicts herself as somebody who was depressed and embattled and sort of lost for years.
例如，她在瓦萨的第一年，她觉得太格格不入了，她开始坐火车去纽约市寻找海洛因，这是她住项目时甚至从未做过的事，直到她因此被学校开除。就好像她走入大学世界越远，她人格中的项目那一面就越被迫通过某种方式表达出来。她把自己描述成一个多年来一直抑郁、陷入困境且迷茫的人。
And the most striking thing about meeting her, if you've read the book, is how completely happy she seems today. She's one of the happiest-seeming people I've ever met, just relaxed, and funny, and at ease. And her feeling about France, the country with this transformation took place, it can be sort of shocking to actual French people.
如果你读过这本书，见到她时最引人注目的事情是她今天看起来是多么完全的快乐。她是我见过看起来最快乐的人之一，放松、有趣、从容。而她对法国的感受——那个发生这种转化的国家——对真正的法国人来说可能有点震惊。
When we just won the Euro 2000, I came to work and I was telling the Moroccan secretary, we won! [SPEAKING FRENCH] And she just glares at me.
当我们刚赢得2000年欧洲杯时，我来工作，我告诉摩洛哥秘书：“我们赢了！[法语对话]”。她只是怒视着我。
Because she was born here. And she says, I'm not French. I'm Moroccan. It's just like black Americans. I'm not American, I'm black.
因为她是在这里出生的。她说：“我不是法国人。我是摩洛哥人。”就像美国黑人一样。“我不是美国人，我是黑人。”
And I was like, we won, we won! And she was like, what are you talking about? You're not even French. What do you mean, we won? I'm like, I'm French in my heart. [LAUGHS]
我说：“我们赢了，我们赢了！”她说：“你在说什么？你根本不是法国人。你什么意思，我们赢了？”我说：“我的心里是法国人。”[笑]
And this black friend of mine was saying, you're the only person I know who could sing "The Marseillaise." That shows how extreme you are. Do you know why?
这个黑人朋友说：“你是唯一一个我认识能唱《马赛曲》的人。”这表明你有多极端。你知道为什么吗？
It's because I say to them, I never had a country. I never had a country. I had a hood. I had Brooklyn.
因为我对他们说：“我从没有国家。我从没有国家。我只有街区。我有布鲁克林。”
But I never felt like I had a country. So now I have a country. It's a little one. We always come in third or fourth place in the Olympics. But it's France.
但我从未觉得我有国家。所以现在我有了国家。它有点小。我们在奥运会上总是拿第三或第四名。但它是法国。
Here's something else. There are certain things about French culture, Janet says, that just make life here very pleasant. For one thing, people don't ask you personal questions-- where you grew up, where you work, what's your family like, what's your story? You're not constantly explaining yourself. She says she has one friend who she knew for five years before she knew this woman had a grown son.
这里还有别的事情。珍妮特说，关于法国文化有某些东西让这里的生活非常愉快。首先，人们不会问你私人的问题——你在哪长大，在哪工作，家庭情况如何，你的故事是什么？你不需要不断解释自己。她说她有个朋友，她认识了五年之后才知道这个女人有个成年的儿子。
Also, there isn't the same striving, the same ambition to be number one as in the States, especially compared with the corporate law job she used to have where everybody was expected to put in 60 and 70 and 80 hours a week. Here, that would be seen as very strange. Work just is not that important to most people.
此外，这里没有同样的目标，没有那种像在美国那样要争第一的雄心，特别是与她过去从事的公司法工作相比——每个人都被预期每周投入60、70、80个小时。在这里，那会被视为非常奇怪。工作对大多数人来说真的不那么重要。
I'll get tears in my eyes. Sometimes I look around the subway, and I look at all these French people, and I'm like, thank you for letting me live here in your country.
我的眼里会流泪。有时我环顾地铁，我看着所有这些法国人，我说：“谢谢你们让我住在你们的国家。”
We head outside.
我们走出去。
But you feel like it's your country, but your identity here isn't that of a French person. It's that of an outsider.
但你觉得那是你的国家，但你在这里的身份不是法国人。而是局外人。
I know. And I think that's what it is to be Project Girl. I was always an outsider. And I feel most inside right now where I'm most outside. Go figure. [LAUGHS]
我知道。我想这就是做一个“项目女孩”的感受。我一直是个局外人。我觉得现在在这个我最像局外人的地方，我最有归属感。去想吧。[笑]
That's what freedom is, though. It's not about nothing left to lose. It's about nothing left to be. You don't have to be anything.
不过，这就是自由。它不是关于“一无所有”。而是关于“无需成为什么”。你不需要成为任何东西。
I was just thinking about it this morning. It's like, I'm an outsider. I will always be a foreigner, no matter how good my French gets. I will never really be French, no matter how much of a wannabe I am. And yet I feel that I'm home. I'm just home.
我今天早上刚才还在想。就像，“我是局外人。”无论我的法语变得多好，我永远是个外国人。无论我多么想成为法国人，我永远不会真正是法国人。然而我觉得我在家。我就是在家。
Around the corner from the Cafe Flore is where the author James Baldwin lived for a while. Janet says she feels like she understands a little of how he must have felt, coming from Harlem, from a family that was always struggling, and then arriving here. Everything is so pretty and so much easier than home.
在花神咖啡馆拐角处就是作者詹姆斯·鲍德温住过一段时间的地方。珍妮特说她觉得她有点理解他当时一定是什么感觉，从哈林区来，从一个一直苦苦挣扎的家庭来，然后到达这里。一切都那么漂亮，比家里容易得多。
Here we are. This is where James Baldwin lived, with that painter, 56 Rue Jacob. But see, he lived way up in the top, on the top floor.
到了。詹姆斯·鲍德温就是住这里，和那个画家，雅各布街56号。但你看，他住在顶楼，顶层。
[INAUDIBLE]. One, two, three, four, fifth floor. It's obviously a walk-up. The cheapest apartments are always on the top because you have to walk farther.
[听不清]。一层，二层，三层，四层，五层。这显然是个没有电梯的公寓。最便宜的公寓总是在最高层，因为你必须爬得更远。
And that's where he was. Wow. He probably even mailed letters at that post office down there. He mailed letters back to Harlem. Hey, and here we are.
那就是他住的地方。哇。他可能甚至在那边的邮局寄信。他寄信回哈林区。嘿，到了。
Baldwin, of course, decided to settle in France permanently. And when Janet first moved Paris, she thought it would just be for a few years. And now, every time she goes home, she sees too much about the United States that she just does not want to deal with anymore. And she's realizing she may never move back.
鲍德温当然决定永久定居在法国。当珍妮特刚搬到巴黎时，她以为只会待几年。现在，每次她回家，她看到太多她不想再处理的关于美国的事情。她意识到她可能永远不会搬回去。
Our program was produced today by Susan Burton and myself, avec Julie Snyder, Blue Chevigny, and Alex Blumberg. Contributing editors for today's program, Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, Alix Spiegel, Nancy Updike, and consigliere Sarah Powell. Additional production on our rerun from Aviva DeKornfeld, Jessica Lussenhop, Katharine Raimondo, Stowe Nelson, and Matt Tierney.
我们今天的节目由苏珊·伯顿和我自己制作，朱莉·斯奈德、布鲁·切维尼和亚历克斯·布隆伯格协助。今天节目的特约编辑有：保罗·托夫、杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林、亚历克斯·斯皮格尔、南希·厄普代克和萨拉·鲍威尔。我们重播节目的额外制作人有：阿维娃·德科恩费尔德、杰西卡·勒森霍普、凯瑟琳·雷蒙多、斯托·尼尔森和马特·蒂尔尼。
Today's program was first broadcast in the year 2000. You can no longer smoke indoors all over Paris. And I hate the fact that I have to say this. Janet McDonald, the writer of Project Girl, who is so wonderful in the third act of the show, and who I kept in touch with after the program, she died in 2007 at the age of 53. Her book is still available.
今天的节目首次播出于2000年。你不能再在巴黎所有的室内抽烟了。我讨厌必须说这一点。珍妮特·麦克唐纳，也就是节目第三幕中如此美妙的《项目女孩》作者，我在节目结束后一直与她保持联系，她在2007年去世了，享年53岁。她的书仍然可以买到。
Eric Satie music was played for us on the accordion by Dean Olsher. Jad Abumrad recorded him. Other musical help today came from the amazing John Connors, Nikki Rinkus, and Kathie Berquist. Special thanks today to Steven Barclay, author of the book A Place in the World Called Paris, and to James Campbell, whose book Exiled in Paris, was a useful summary of all the facts surrounding Richard Wright and James Baldwin's years in Paris. Also, thanks to Sandrine Rastello and [? Catherine ?] Johnstone.
埃里克·萨蒂的音乐由迪恩·奥尔舍为我们在手风琴上演奏。贾德·阿布姆拉德录制了他。今天其他音乐帮助来自令人惊叹的约翰·康纳斯、尼基·林库斯和凯西·伯奎斯特。今天特别感谢史蒂芬·巴克莱，他著有《世界上的一个地方叫巴黎》，以及詹姆斯·坎贝尔，他的书《流亡巴黎》是对理查德·赖特和詹姆斯·鲍德温在巴黎生活的有用总结。还要感谢桑德琳·拉斯泰洛和[？凯瑟琳·]约翰斯通。
Our website is ThisAmericanLife.org, where you can hear our archive of nearly 700 episodes for absolutely free. Or download our app. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who reminds you, don't forget, please, learn from the experiences of others.
我们的网站是ThisAmericanLife.org，在那里你可以免费听到我们近700集的档案。或者下载我们的应用程序。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交易所分发给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托瑞·马拉蒂亚先生，他提醒你：请不要忘记，从别人的经历中学习。
Dinner at Hugh and David's. The butter was terrible.
晚餐在休和戴维家。那黄油太糟糕了。
That's right. I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of this American life.
那是真的。我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周再见，会有更多美国生活的报道。
[MUSIC - ANDY WILLIAMS, "AU REVOIR PARIS"]
[音乐 - 安迪·威廉姆斯，“再见，巴黎”]